okay everybody we're going to start and
I prepared this game to show you it's a
very fresh game played in Norway chess
2016 between onigiri one of the
participants of the upcoming simple Cup
tournament starting tomorrow and against
indian grandmaster hari krishna and this
was excellent display for the Indian
Grand Master who who was a little bit
lower rated than Hari Krishna a little
bit low rated but still very high 2763
but he managed to win with black and he
played a French my favourite opening
that I played for a very long time for
27 years I played a French so always
very exciting to see a French victory d4
d5 Knight c3 Knight f6 when they play 93
what line is this of the French defense
what line is this of the French defence
now we know where it's been black plays
Bishop before if black plays Bishop
before yes that's going to be been aware
but this is not that so so what is this
going to be here
when he plays 93 that's a different line
and that's called classical cancer maybe
that is the classical variation of the
French so against classical we can play
Bishop before we know where we can take
only for Rubenstein or we can play
Knight f6 line okay that forces the e5
okay let's call it this is called
classical system
nine goes on d7 white pushes white is
gaining some centers c5 Knight f3 Bishop
e7 normally you play knight c6 here but
here he played Bishop e7 Bishop e3
Castle Queen d2 and here very
interesting move here play by Hari
Krishna he is trying to solve the
problem of the light square bishop which
is it's it's a common knowledge that
this light square bishop is our problem
so that's why we are trying to get rid
of this problem okay so that's why we
choose the move b6 we play b6 in order
to play Bishop to a6 that's the idea now
Bishop comes a six and we are trying to
exchange ok so again remember that
that's the biggest problem in the French
is your light square bishop so when you
get a chance you want to try to exchange
the bishop okay so remember that so it
goes 90185
see three a four
the a5 and then we're trying to play a
for to put some pressure gaining some
space it's important to gain space so
that's why he's playing a four move the
next move is going to be Bishop h6 so
Bishop d3 he's waiting for Bishop d3 and
now time to play which move excellent
excellent job bish page six now he
castles knight c6 developing the problem
of the ducks light-square bishop is
about to be solved any moment and the
question is will remain if y can attack
if white cannot attack with f5 then
black is going to be doing absolutely
fine so it goes Bishop takes a6 rook
takes a six and now DD decided to attack
so he played a5
do you see why black didn't want to take
the pawn here for a moment it looks like
it's just a free free pawn but actually
in reality it's not a free form what is
the problem can you see what is the
problem
Martin it weakens our Center a little
bit because then he can also click wind
III attacking the rook and attacking the
F pawn yes so if you take unfortunately
this runs into quindi tree attack the
rook attacked upon you play c4 Queen
takes f5 okay that is the problem so
that's why after he plays f5 we need to
make a good move here what we can do
here okay now what did he play here see
a lot of people would have started
panicking right away after f5 it looks
very looks very threatening and kind of
dangerous but in fact white doesn't have
you know bless you the immediate threat
seen out here so let's try to find it
let's try to find some good ideas here
3595 is interesting yes
but the problem is the problem is 95
your night on d7 is going to be very
passive so that is your problem okay
so that's why he doesn't necessarily
want to play b5 here okay
now and also the rook is going to be
hanging so there's going to be some
problems with like Queen d3 move so
that's why he didn't want to play the
move Knight a5
so what else yes
c4 is a possibility yes but then you
kind of lock in your contra player seat
before he may take take a three and then
everything is locked up everything is
going to be locked up so it's not so
clear now in the move he makes
it gives him some advantage but also it
doesn't completely lock up the position
so let's see if you can find that move
what did Hari Krishna play here very
strong move in this position he did to
keep the pressure Queen c7 that is a
possibility that's a possibility but
still that the rook is being loose
theory now so that is a little problem
the rook being loose so that's the
little concern there you know he didn't
want the rook to be a loose - what is it
okay Queenie hits is interesting when it
is certainly interesting but he wants
and he wants to keep the bishop here he
wants to have the Queen here to control
a position okay so that's what he is
trying to do what else what else you can
try to do here think about it yes d5
that is the correct answer that's what
he played b5 that stops the Queen d3
attack and in the future he also gives
them the option to play like before or
something like that so that's why V 5 is
a very calm move so
now he takes he takes back I'm not sure
maybe it perhaps some type of sacrifice
like f6 could have been interesting
maybe g4 could even play because really
after he took he doesn't really have
anything it looks like they created a
weakness but it's so difficult to attack
this it's almost impossible to attack
this with something so that's why you
know play d5 f takes is six F takes is
six Queen e2 now you get e one of the
top players in the world is attacking
the pawn on b5 the pawn on b5 now needs
to be protected what can you do here
again you don't want to play c4 because
that's going to completely lock the
position after a3 and you don't have any
breakthroughs on this side of the board
and slowly you know he will put some
pressure on this you might find yourself
in trouble okay so that's why you don't
necessarily want to play c4 here okay so
what can you do here that you keep the
tension and also activate and develop
another piece here Martin that's a
possibility but your root is already in
the game there is a piece that is not
developed so we want to try to develop
the piece that is not developed yes
correct answer Queen b6 yes that's
developing the Queen and putting
pressure on d4 as much as possible
okay well earlier we didn't want to move
but that an opposition has changed a
little bit now we have pressure okay
pressure on d4
he goes Knight f2 and here I think you
should have played the move a tree
anyhow this a tree move was important to
play a three to control the before
square because he didn't play a three
and then that allowed black to play a
tree and then before that that what
happened in also I think this was a
mistake right here he made because if he
had played the right move
then position is more or less equal so
but now he played Knight f2 and can you
take advantage of this moment here that
he didn't play a tree what can you do
first now you push a tree and that's
what he played a tree putting pressure
on b2 he goes b3 and now the for Martin
very good very good
attacking the chain right attacking that
chain and now this is very important to
win this and also this pawn on a3 is a
very strong pawn it's a match pond okay
it's a very important pawn in in the end
game if you win the a to pawn this one
is going to give you the victory because
it's so further advanced and that's
exactly how he won this game okay so
it's a big advantage it's a big plus for
you to have a pawn like that because
then if you win the H open you're going
to be able to win the game alright so
remember that
so here white already regretted he
certainly regretted this move Knight of
two here because his Center is now
collapsing he should have played a tree
and he decided he cannot hold the center
anymore so I decided to simplify the
position so he took bishop takes he took
Knight takes c4 what to do if it takes
this Knight is going to land on before
putting a lot of pressure so he decided
to play c4 at least to try to keep the
position you know a little bit closed
I mean block is already slightly better
but white white ISM try to you know
fight as much as possible now very good
move you have here a very good move you
have here let's see if you can find it
active you need to play active so you
can seize the initiative here and try to
get advantage yes very nice very good
thinking Knight e4 activating the night
first of all you put in pressure
right and then yes you want to put this
knight on c3 that's exactly what you're
trying to do okay so he decided to take
to give you weakness and then II six the
problem for white he cannot put the rook
on d1 because it runs into Knight c3
idea so that's why he plays c6 in six
trying to create some complications he's
really trying to complicate the matters
now what to do here aha a ninety four
ninety a 96 to d4 my d4
oh there's a the problem is your rook
later will be hanging yeah he will take
and when you take you might be able to
take a look that's right we can't really
move the Queen away here so yeah
otherwise ninety four will have been a
nice idea because then you would swing
your rook over to e6 and win some so now
guess you Shawn
Knight what which Knight is excellent
Jack correct answer okay 97 the reason
this is the correct answer because you
protect your little bit weak pawn and
now you simply want to capture this pawn
once you take this one you're just
simply going to be up upon now you have
pressure so it goes King h1 Knight c3
Alex excellent Queen d3 you didn't want
to take on e6 because I think once you
take here there could be some problems
because getting loose Knight jumps in a
little bit of pressure so that's why it
doesn't really want to take the pawn so
the five plane is h6 move it's a very
strong move actually because first of
all it stops all this Knight g5 attacks
with jump it also gives the King an
escape square so it's a it's an
excellent move it's an excellent move
overall to stop all the contra play so
now he goes night to d1 he's trying to
exchange this night because that way you
can at least eliminate this powerful
piece here now the question is what
should black do here very strong move
again
very strong move let's see if you can
find this move yes not oh yeah you could
take the pawn but if you just take the
pawn he will take take and Queen takes
and he wins a comeback and it's going to
be more or less equal now what is the
idea here very strong move actually so
let's see if we can if you can find that
it's a real grandmaster move here strong
grandmaster move so think for a little
bit because if this Knight gets
eliminated then things are going to
start hanging things are going to start
hanging so what are we going to do okay
yes Alex
yeah you could do that you could do that
probably but then maybe he will try to
go 93 and I before try to get a little
bit of activities so what else you have
huh
Queen c6 is possible yeah
then we probably captures pawn captures
94 we don't want him to capture our
Knight that's the key here because if he
captures then we will lose our advantage
here so what can we do here that he
doesn't capture our Knight it's a little
bit of tactical idea involved here it's
really a difficult move but you can find
it
now let's see if you can find the
following move here
Alex yeah Knight takes a - yeah but
that's losing a piece I don't think it's
worth it to lose a piece okay one yeah
I don't think I don't think we want to
sacrifice a piece to win a pawn I don't
think so
that's bit too much yeah but what if you
just say thank you and takes it quint
x-default ah f8 is I see I see very
smart yes
d4 no it's it's an interesting move but
he played this move Queen d5 really
powerful move that's a very serious move
that's like the point is now the Queen
has been the best piece for white for a
long time defending and trying to
combine some attacks so when opponent
has acted piece what do we do trade him
off right and that's what we
accomplishing here by playing Queen d3
we're just simply training the Queen's
off okay so Queen takes Knight takes now
this is hanging well
rook e1 doesn't help too much because
rook f6 and I think this pawn is gone we
going to take this guy so that's why he
goes Knight f2 rook takes c6 now black
is enjoying the extra pawn and on top of
it he has this pawn in the c3 square to
work with so it doesn't get better than
this
93 white is trying to at least create
some kind of contra play so it doesn't
just lose without any contrabass so he
goes 96 rook FC 1
now Luke fc-1 with idea to call rook c5
perhaps and again you know to to create
some some culture play now what can
black do here Martin excellent job yes
Knight to c3 now you trying to block
this and now you want to play d4 to
strengthen the position so he goes
Knight takes before night takes before
rook takes c3 he actually wins the pawn
back but the problem is you're a tree
pond is still remaining you have a now a
very powerful Knight on before and what
are you going to do next
what are you going to do next now to win
upon at least Keyshawn rookie - yes
attacking the a to pawn a very important
point that cannot be captured that
cannot be protected Brooke c7 comes in
with a threat to get behind it if you
play an accurate move now you're going
to lose the pond because rook is going
to get behind it so which move is very
important to play here before we try to
even capture any of the puns which room
is very important here to play yes very
strong Martin yes
rook a8 stopping the rook a seven ideas
he cannot do any of that anymore
94 attacking the rook the rook takes a
two rook rook takes now it goes back
rook f1 now it goes through calf one
because if it takes obviously just
Knight takes you go back you're gonna
win so he goes here he wants to maybe
come in here it's not going to be easy
obviously but what is the winning movie
the game ended in two more moves play
Licata Krishna this was a very
impressive victory against giri by block
very impressive victory let's see if you
can find it
RB - you could play RB - but better I
don't think you played RB - Ruby - it's
probably winning - I have no doubt it's
winning yes how about this move how
about Rd - and simply attacking the
knight now we are attacking the knight
on d4 if he moves it to let's say f3 we
go route B - that's the idea okay
so now he tried his last trick last
trick now h3 hoping you take and maybe
he gets this in as some kind of drawing
ideas probably still not going to work
but we're not gonna fall for that right
so now what is the winning move here
that is going to make white resign now
how are you going to make him resign
here we don't want to take because if we
take we're gonna if we take we're going
to lose well madam lose we're going to
give some chances so what is the winning
move here what is the winning move here
which one correct answer a - passed
pawns they meant to be pushed remember
and the good thing about it Gary
resigned here no more moves because if
he goes here you go check and say check
and then you say take at night and on
top of that you protect the weakness he
takes you take he takes you take and you
have a very powerful position okay
rook is coming to a2 and taking
everything got it
white is a UH nice giri one of the
grandmasters who is playing a tournament
here he's a super grandmaster and black
was a player from India also super
Grandmaster Hari Krishna Pantelleria
Krishna so Blackwall actually against a
higher ranked opponent by using this
very impressive display of the French
defense okay guys excellent everybody
did very well so at the end what I like
to do now do like a one nice study we'll
see maybe we'll be able to do two but
this one to see how good you are in
solving the studies okay let's see how
good you are in solving the studies the
study is a little bit long so I'm just
going to get down to the crucial moment
here okay white to play white to play
and win white to play and win we have to
find you know it's not a force solution
so don't just think it's going to be
check check and you win in some point
you're going to have to find some nice
idea okay so don't rush okay no no let's
think a little bit more we don't want to
just say mama we want to try to get a
little bit more if we can okay a little
bit more and we get the solution so
let's not rush a little bit with the
answer we have to start with a forcing
sequence but at some point we're going
to need a quiet mocha we're going to
need a quiet move at some point so
forcing sequence and a quiet move okay
yes what's the forcing sequence here
okay he's got the first move right
that's a forcing sequence but now you
need to find a very nice move here you
need to find a good move impressive move
right here let's see if you can do that
King before it's very close but
unfortunately you probably miss this
check and then your King is going to get
hunted down and with a lot of checks
okay
so this way you're not going to be able
to win so what are we going to do here
idea is right actually his idea is right
it's just you need to find a better
placement if you can find a better
placement I'm giving you a hint actually
by saying that you're going to be able
to win this so what is the idea here
right
what is the idea here we try to find a
square to Shawn King D to correct good
job
yes now same idea as you but the
difference is now do you see a check now
is there any check now no right because
if check on d7 we take but you can ask
me wait a minute but we're not
threatening anything this is one of
those positions where you're not reading
anything but anything he makes is going
to make his position worse
zooks one very good zooks one yes that
means he is in big trouble
any move he makes it's going to make his
position worse if he goes here checkmate
okay it goes your checkmate if it goes
away checkmate
so you can't really do anything so it
moves clean check mess is really really
stuck Queen takes e5 Queen d7 check so
it's really really difficult position
okay for him and most importantly he he
doesn't have a check if he had a check
then he would have been able to stop
your contra play so this sequence is
check he comes up here and simply we're
taking the two and now he doesn't have
any more checks so this shows us when we
trying to solve this kind of positions
we're not always looking for check check
check solution sometimes we have that
but often times also we're going to have
an idea that is going to involve a quiet
move okay quiet move and then eventually
that can result into a better position
for you so that's why look for quiet
moves as well not only for the forcing
moves sometimes the quiet move is going
to be the one that is going to give you
a way like in this position is an
excellent example of Suk's Juan where
you know Bach is in sook savant anything
he plays is going to make his position
even worse okay
all right very good so any questions you
have regarding the first game
everybody understand ideas of that
French defense how we manage to do it a
five and Bishop a six plump so that was
very important and to understand how the
top our masters play so and to play the
a5 v6
Bishop a six ideas so we had a couple of
French players that I know I'm familiar
with so and sound the new students here
definitely can add this to their repair
to our against the e4 and use this ideas